TPARDON A CONVICTEDERER BEFOREI
THE CONFLICT
OBL THIS
ONE WE R
THIS ONE. WE HAVE TOE WEAPON. AA
TS AND INCLUDED THOSE GOD
GIVEN RIGHTS RIGHT TO
SELF DEFENSE.G YOU UP TO
ST LEGALLYALLY PROTEGDEATH OF GE
AAKEL
HIM GUILTY O MURDERE DR M
EVEN BN ET
SEG ABBOT HTE
PERRY.N TEXAS. THE GOVERNOR
NT A PARDON AFTER
THE F
ECOMMENDATIO. TT RN EXPED
REVIEW OFHIS CASE. I
NOTE THAT WEIT ON THIS
THIS WEEK TO JOIN US. NOW WE
IDT IS CASE, JOSEOINS US AND
BEEN SENTN EADY THEOV IS
MOISN MY THE
FOSTER ABOUTNT FIANC. THEY
WAITED SO LO THEIR
TRAVIS COUNTYTRTORNEYT. O CICE G
T FOSTER. HAVE YOU SPOK
HTHE OPPORTUNITY
FA
AD THETO TODAY. UM, I
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SOON. OTB
OKAY G THAT YOU'VEOK TONRTANT PT
E S MEMBERS HERE AREPOTEGOVERNOL
SIGN IT. IHIS PAR
HAPPEN, DO YOU THINK IT
UNDERMINES YOUR OFFICE? WEL
SIMPLY BY MAKING
UNDERMINED THE RUL OLA IN
THE STATE OF TASUR LESS SINGLE S
COUNTY, WED  C ACTS OFGU VIOLENR
EOPLE
CO WHO COMMIT ACTS OFND OBVIOLYI
HAS IT'S SO OUS TTO
ANO THE SITTIRNOR OF TEXAS
ON THIS SHOW ON MONDAY.
ANDWANTEDAS I
A PDOELRRY.ASONORRE
ANDALK K INSTEAD S THATGREGION.O
RIGHT D
SYT IS PEOPLE DEMOCRACY IT I WHE
SAVER THE WEEND
PEOPLE
IT TROUBLING THAT
SOMEONE LAR M POWER IN THE STE
TEXAS AND THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
HERE ANDTT GARZAFOTH
TE TATTHERRE
TONIGHT. THANK YOU. KNOW THE
YOU KNLE AORNEYPO BEFORE? I WONT
SAS ERODE THE
MAENT, AND S ITHECKRESSIVEOSECUO
KTEIND OF
PROGREE APPROACHBL
SAFET AND WHAT'S HAPPENING CLAT
POLITICS? THE
SHO COMING THE FOTHERS. THERE WN
T OF IO. THEY
ACTUALLY CREATED A CIVILLAW WHOD
LESEEE BUMST. WANT
, AND AOTGO  CROWD
WI THE POTENTIAL
PAON THAT
'VE TALKED
ABOUT TE FACSERIOUS
POLITICAL HEADWINDS FOR THE SOR
OF YOU MAKE O?ME IS
SAYING I DEF
STANDARD I T TLET THE SENTENCINE
DELIBETIF ORSENT A LONG TVERS DE
WHO WASDEIN BACIN.RERTER,
MURDERITHUN, WMURDER FROME U
JAIL TWO YEARS EAR
DGO EPE
HEAD OF THE NARA ATHEYOTB THAT
MARKSMANS WING THAT
FIRST ENDORSE AFTER 100
YED REA I19 THAT'S80 MIL
IN THIS COY POLITICALE
OF SNIZATION WAS AOMENT
SEEING THAT PLAY OUT NOW. THIS
IS LIKE NO KUSE'S THE WR, YOU FT
MTCHOOSE S
BS FEELS LIKE
PPOINTED TO REMEMBER. YOU
WHERE HE THAT P POSTED THATA
DAY, YOU KNO TO KILL APL TO WORN
MIGHT GO TO DALLAS TO SHOOT THEG
ONE OM.THEYPS OUT IS THAT
AB IS THAT THE
UNDERCUTS HIS LOGIC.RONG, WHICHE
SO STRONG AND THE DUDE STILL GOT
CONVD
I'M HERE TOELE REALLDERSTANDINGT
SOMEBODY
ESPLENA NO. THIS ISN'T
S,
THESONLL CONVICTED.
THATEALLY
THWS. YOU KNOWEE
ENT DOIN SAYING IS
VE IMPORTANT. THE IDEA THATOTUSS
TOSO
AO  IRONY OF THIS.
THET
WASF. THEA WAS
HIM. THEREBY H S
EFE'M SCARED,
THEY'RE LEGALLY WE REALLY GOT WY
DEFINITION, ITSCARY TN
OUAISED
N
E THE AK. BUTONNA DO AGAIN TEX S
THAT DOESNAK A
ABERAR SOMEBODY
WAHE
SAHE
DO SETO ALLACT LWE